liebes tagebuch heute morgen war ich mit
kelly beim sport und später konnte man
sogar meine muskeln sehen
danach habe ich henry begrüßt gomez
wollte lieber am karton weiter kaum
ich fand beim einkaufen einen
adventskranz der von 30 euro 5 reduziert
war und habe ihn natürlich mitgenommen
danach bekam ich eine mail in der das
fertige motive meine drin war und ich
war zu dumm um ein handy richtig rum zu
halten
nach dem duschen habe ich dann von
meinem adventskalender das zweite
türchen aufgemacht
heute war schokolade drin dann habe ich
die süße eule von elisa gestreichelt
fürs mittagessen habe ich aus meiner
letzten grapefruit den saft gepresst
dazu gab es teigtaschen mit angebratenen
zwiebeln es war sehr lecker
heute hatte ich die mobs hose und den
tell you got no polieren tolles gefühl
mein outfit of the day am meisten die
socken als ich aber meine füße hin und
her bewegt habe mochte er sie nicht mehr
danach habe ich versucht mit handy ein
katzen video nachzuspielen
aber er wollte lieber dass ich ihm den
bauch kraulen dann habe ich das foto von
max und mir mit dem weihnachtsmann
gefunden weil ich langsam müde wurde
habe ich mir einen cappuccino gemacht es
war sehr schwer die kamera während
dessen zu halten und deshalb habe ich
einmal den becher nicht getroffen
das hat mich völlig raus gebracht und
ich hab vergessen die löffel weiter zu
zählen
danach habe ich wette aufgegangen
henry wollte mir helfen und ist in den
wäschekorb geklettert doch dann hat es
ihm zu sehr gestunken und erst
weggelaufen
dann war der akku von der legria fertig
aufgeladen und ich fand dass ich
ziemlich lustig mit fischer aussehen um
mich ein bisschen zu entspannen habe ich
mit henry gekuschelt thomas kam nach dem
essen dazu und er wollte wissen wie die
leg gericht die beiden machen mich sehr
glücklich und ich muss immer sehr lachen
plötzlich mussten die beiden sich putzen
erst die eine wange und dann die andere
und zum schluss haben sie versucht sich
ihre brust zu putzen
was aber ehrlich gesagt ziemlich dem es
aussieht henry fand es auf meinem schoß
dann doch gemütlich und mir ist
aufgefallen wie komisch meine haare
aussehen und dass ich zum friseur muss
gomez konnte sich nicht entscheiden ob
er lieber spielt oder sich weiter fort
und henry auch nicht dann musste ich die
beiden verlassen damit ich weiter in dem
video schneiden kann was ich mit mirella
und kelly zusammen gedreht habe ende